la suite du procès de patrick dils à
lyon journée importante car la cour
d'assises est revenu sur les
incertitudes concernant l'heure du crime
des deux enfants un détail qui compte
en préambule patrick dils encore une
fois très combatif a réaffirmé son
innocence sur place dominique verdeilhan
patrick descheemaecker mieux que
personne ses parents le savent
patrick dils n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
je pense que ses avocats ont dit de
préparer ça doit bien ça devrait bien se
passer
micro en main s'adressant aux jurés il
revient sur ses aveux
j'avais 16 ans j'ai été terrorisé pour
moi ce n'était qu'un scénario j'ai
raconté ce qui m'a été suggéré des aveux
répétés plusieurs fois devant les
policiers le juge pourquoi ne pas être
revenu en arrière plus tôt s'interroge
perfidement la présidence j'étais rentré
dans un mécanisme impossible à gérer
répond l'accusé puis giresse qui lui a
peut-être manqué à ce moment là c'est
qu'un adulte et ça ne pouvait être qu'à
n'annule le prennent par l'épaule et lui
lise arrête de raconter tout ça puisque
c'est tout cela est faux l'avocat
général s'inquiète lui des multiples
détails donnés par l'accusé vous en dit
beaucoup
vous aviez bonne mémoire renchéri la
présidente pour les parties civiles le
procès de lyon est une répétition de
celui de rats comprend mieux maintenant
au niveau de l'opinion publique
j'imagine mieux les personnes qui
assistent dans ce procès public
que patrick dils a pu être condamnée par
la cour d'assises de reims après la
révision de son procès un face-à-face
lourd pressent assurément un tournant
dans ce troisième procès on en a presque
oublié les premiers mots de l'accusé en
début d'audience
j'ai gardé le coeur la parole et les
yeux d'un enfant je n'ai pas vécu j'ai
survécu